نحن الان وسط مدينه ترمانين بريف ادلب وسط
اكوام ركام ست مباني دمرها الزلزال الذي
ضرب هذه المنطقه تشاهدون الدمار الكبير
الذي خلفه الزلزال مباني دمرت وقضت عائلات
باكملها تحت الركام وفق الدفاع المدني فان
هناك
عشرين شخصا قد قتل تحت انقاض الركام بينما
بلغ عدد الناجين نحو 20 شخصا وقد تمكن
الدفاع عن مدني قبل قليل من استخراج اخر
العالقين من تحت الانقاب بينما يقوم
المدنيون الان هنا بمتابعه اعمال البحث
والتاكد من عدم وجود جثث تحت الانقاض
وكذلك يقومون بعمليه البحث عن امتعتهم وما
يستطيعون استخراجه
لكن بادوات بسيطه وهذه الصوره لربما هي
تكشف وتلخص الوضع الذي يعيش هؤلاء
المنكوبون وحجم الكارثه هنا
تشاهدون بايديهم العاريه
بايديهم وادوات بسيطه جدا
ما في عندكم ادوات ما في لادوات ولا عم
نشتغل فيديو هدول الموجودين
طيب ما طلبت المساعده من حدا ما وصلكم شي
نطلب مساعده اول شيء من رب العالمين
ثاني شيء اللي بده يساهم يساهم لحاله من
غير تطور كما تشاهدون الكبار والصغار
الجميع هنا جميع المتضررين من هذا الزلزال
يقومون في الحقيقه نستطيع ان نقول بغوص
انفسهم بمساعده انفسهم بانفسهم الدفاع
المدني كان يعمل هنا لكنه توجه الى اماكن
اخرى مستعجله واكثر تضررا وما يزال فيها
اناس تحت الانقاض هذه هي الصوره هنا
الجميع هنا في حاله كارثيه وهؤلاء
المتضررون كما تشاهدون هم بامس الحاجه
وينتظرون المساعدات والكوادر التي تساعدهم
سواء في انتشال من بقي تحت الانقاض او حتى
كذلك في مساعدتهم وفي عمليات غوسهم
عمرو حلبي الجزيره من بلده ترمانين